hello everyone and thank you for
attending my presentation today
entitled using a predictive
bioinformatics algorithm of difficult
neoantogen peptide synthesis
for precision amino oncology therapeutic
development
today's presentation will be separated
into four main sections
first i will give a brief introduction
into the world of neo-antigen-based
personalized immuno-oncology
therapeutics
next i will give an overview of how
neoantogen peptides are utilized during
precision therapeutic development
and why neoantigen peptides are so
difficult to synthesize
then i will review genscript's four-tier
platform for synthesizing difficult
neoantigen peptides
highlighting our proprietary algorithm
for predicting neopeptide synthetic
difficulty
before finishing up the summary and
15-minute q a section
as many of you will unfortunately
understand first-hand or through a
personal connection
cancer is the world's second leading
cause of death only behind cardiac
arrest
in 2018 alone 17 million people were
diagnosed with cancer in the united
states
with unfortunately 56 percent of them
passing due to the disease
so with a 70 increase in cancer
diagnosis
over the past 20 years and 9.5 million
people dying from cancer in the us alone
in 2018
researchers and clinicians have realized
that standard methods
of care such as chemotherapy radiation
and other one-size-fits-all treatments
are not negating the disease as quickly
as cancer mutates
to avoid therapeutic efficacy therefore
we need a new standard method of care
such as personalized immunotherapy
immunotherapies for cancer treatment
have been around for almost 10 years
however current treatments will only
target shared targets such as oncogenes
tumor-associated antigens or immune
checkpoints
checkpoints are receptors on the surface
of t cells which
when bound by their ligand are able to
inhibit t-cell-based immune response
against target cells
many cancer cells are able to avoid
immune detection
the expression of pdl-1 the ligand for
pd-1
which will bind t-cell checkpoints and
inhibit immune attack
checkpoint inhibitors are proteins which
block specific immune checkpoints
such as pd-1 and initiate a
t-cell-mediated immune response against
the tumor
through binding of the t-cell receptor
or tcr
and the tumor-associated antigen
clinical trials using checkpoint
inhibitors have shown great potential
although the effect is limited in many
cases especially in solid tumors
where checkpoint inhibitors cannot make
direct contact with the tumor
microenvironment
another common immunotherapy against
shared tumor-associated antigens or
t-cell therapies
there are many different forms of t-cell
therapy however
the goal of each form is the same to
target patient or healthy donor t-cells
to the tumor to bind to a tumor
biomarker
and initiate an anti-tumor killing
response
to generate t cell therapies patients
autologous t lymphocytes or donor
matched allergenic t
cells are genetically modified to
express tcrs
which bind to specific tumor-associated
antigens
these t-cells are then expanded in vitro
and reinfused back into the patient
these tcr's can be standard tcrs or they
can be chimeric antigen receptors
that are known as cars which on top of
having a tumor-associated antigen
binding domain or taw
they contain an internal switchboard
which when bound to its target
activates the t cell to initiate an
immune cascade
clinical trials have shown great promise
for these therapeutics as well
however they also show poor efficacy in
solid tumors
and tumors with high mutational burden
due to immune escape
despite showing promise
one-size-fits-all or off-the-shelf-style
immunotherapies have shown limited
efficacy
and about 70 percent of tumors but why
well there are two common ways cancer
evades the immune system
as well as ta targeted therapeutics
those are anagen escape and weak
immunogenicity
anagen escape is a natural caveat of
cancer's high mutational nature
in which shared tumor antigens are
either completely or partially down
regulated
allowing tumors to evade single target
therapies like checkpoint inhibitors and
car t
immunogenicity occurs when oncogenic
tumor-associated antigens
are also expressed in healthy tissue
just on a lower scale
and therefore are recognized as
self-antigen because of this
immune cells will not initiate an immune
response and cancerous tissue will
remain unscathed
however both of these common problems
can be avoided by using personalized
immunotherapies
as opposed to one-size-fits-all
treatments but what exactly is precision
medicine
in precision medicine individual patient
tumors are biopsied
and used for ngs whole exome sequencing
rna sequencing and proteome
identification
through bioinformatics analysis of these
sequences
compared to healthy tissue clinicians
can identify treatments which will work
for the specific tumor biomarkers
present in that patient's tumor there
are two types of precision medicine
first is to match patient tumor
biomarkers to a database of clinical and
therapeutics
known to be efficacious for those
specific biomarkers
second are personalized therapeutics
which are designed from scratch to
target patient tumor-specific antigens
known as neoantigens the main topic of
today's presentation
neoantogens are new or novel cancer
antigens which are present on the
cancerous tissue
but not expressed within wild-type
tissue they are expressed within
individual tumors or tumor cells of a
specific patient
rather than being shared amongst
patients suffering from one type of
cancer
neoantigens are expressed as peptides
within cancerous tissue
from single amino acid deletions and or
insertions
known as indels in rare instances
neoantogens can also be expressed from
frameshift mutations
because of how they are generated
neoantogens tend to be highly
hydrophobic in nature
as well as having a strong tendency to
aggregate however since they are
minimally affected by anagen escape or
weak immunogenicity
they make great targets for
immunotherapy
there are four main reasons why
neo-antigens are preferred targets for
personalized immunotherapy
first normally neoantigens are not
expressed at a high enough level to be
tracked by the immune system but because
they are not recognized as self-antigens
like common taus they are highly
immunogenic
therefore directing targeting can
enhance the natural immunogenicity of
neoantigens
to elicit a strong anti-tumor killing
immune response
secondly once a neo antigen forms there
is a low chance of it mutating again
and leading to a therapeutic antigenic
scape as it is not an important protein
for oncolytic survival
third some neoantigen therapeutics such
as personalized cancer vaccines
tend to target multiple neoantigens
simultaneously
avoiding the possibility of immune
escape even if one neoantigen was to
mutate
and be untargetable lastly each
neoantigen can be matched to specific
tcrs
and therefore their immune response can
be closely analyzed in vitro
before being used in a possible
therapeutic
there are two main therapeutic types
which target cancer neoantigens
personalized cancer vaccines or pcds and
t-cell therapies
personalized cancer vaccines work
similarly to infectious disease vaccines
and that they introduce small peptide
components of the biological threat you
are trying to initiate an immune
response against
in the case of a pcv this will be cancer
neo antigens
since every pcv is generated for a
specific patient
the first step in production will be to
take a tumor biopsy
this sample will then be sent to the lab
where it will be used for
ngs next generation sequencing rna
sequencing and immunopeptide
identification
these sequences will be compared with
sequences from healthy wild-type tissue
using bioinformatics tools
in order to identify the mutanome or
mutations present within cancerous
tissue
that are not expressed in wild-type
cells
the metanome will then be put through
bioinformatics algorithms
to identify the predictive
immunogenicity and pcv efficacy of each
individual neoantigen
the top neoantogen peptide candidates
will be synthetically produced and used
for in-vitro functionality screening
in order to confirm the predicted
activity of each candidate
from these results clinicians will first
decide on the 20 or so neo antigens
which they plan to use for their
patients pcb
and secondly decide which modality they
will use
to introduce those neo antigens to the
patient's lymphatic system
the most common modalities include
neo-antigen dna
mrna peptide or post antigen presenting
cells mixed with varying delivery
vehicles and adjuvants
once formalized the vaccine will be
placed directly into the patient's
lymphatic system
through injection in order to be
processed and presented by patient apcs
and initiate a t-cell-based
anti-tumor-killing immune response
against cancerous tissue expressing
those neoantigen epitopes
the second main therapeutic targeting
neoantogens are personalized t cell
therapies
the main difference between personalized
t-cell therapies and off-the-shelf
treatments i described earlier
is that they are tailored to immunogenic
neoantigen on patient-specific tumors
similar to pcvs the first stage of
personalized t-cell development
is to biopsy and sequence the patient's
tumor to identify the mutanum
which is put through bioinformatics
algorithms to identify neoantigens
are predicted to initiate a strong
immune cascade when they bind to tcrs
these neoantigen candidates will be
synthetically produced
and screened for therapeutic efficacy in
order to identify the perfect neoantogen
for an individual's tumor
from there a tcr will be engineered to
express binding domains
for that specific neoantogen and cloned
into patient-specific
known as autologous or healthy donor
known as allergenic t
cells those t cells are expanded and
infused into the patient
in order to elicit an anti-tumor-killing
immune response
no matter the type of neoantigen
targeted therapeutic researchers will
require production of synthetic
neoantigen peptides during three phases
first neoantogen peptides are required
for preclinical functionality screening
of bioinformatics candidates
for t cell therapy these peptides will
be utilized for tcr binding affinity and
immunogenicity analysis
while neoantogen candidates for pcv
development will be used for t cell
stimulation assays such as ellie spots
flow cytometry and cytotoxicity assays
after a new therapeutic has been
developed it will be
first tested in animals such as mice and
non-human primates
not just for efficacy testing but mainly
for safety and toxicity of
novel additions to the therapeutic such
as adjuvants and delivery vehicles like
lipo or nanoparticles
for this stage of development of pcvs
neoantigen peptides will be used as
model vaccines to inject into the
animals
as well as for post-clinical efficacy
screening
during this phase whether it be in
animals or human patients
neoantogen peptides are utilized to
ensure that the intervention
initiated an immune response which can
be continuously used to target and kill
neoantogen expressing cancerous tissue
despite neoantigen peptides being
required for multiple stages of
personalized therapeutic development
they tend to be the bottleneck for many
researchers trying to produce these
treatments in a timely manner
due to the difficulty of neoantogen
peptide synthesis
but how do we synthesize peptides
let's review the basics of synthetic
peptide synthesis
peptides can be produced using either
recombinant or synthetic technologies
recombinant synthesis is simply
expressing the peptide within a
microorganism
through standard plasma transfection and
peptide purification
chemical synthesis on the other hand is
much more involved but basically a resin
is used to anchor the first amino acid
in the peptide chain
while additional amino acids are added
one by one through a standard
dehydration reaction between the amino
and carboxyl groups of the supporting
and incoming amino acid these two
synthetic methodologies can also be
combined
depending on the specific amino acid
sequence which needs to be produced
at genscript we prefer to use synthetic
peptide production
because it's easier to custom design any
peptide sequence
produce longer peptides through ligation
of shorter fragments
and to generate large-scale peptides
while recombinant expression has
limitations
for incorporating unnatural amino acids
or modifications
it's difficult to synthesize hydrophobic
peptides
an overexpression of membrane peptides
can actually harm the cell and lead to
cell death
let's dive a little deeper into chemical
peptide production
chemical peptide synthesis most often
occurs by coupling the carboxyl group
of the incoming amino acid to the
n-terminus of the growing peptide chain
this c to n synthesis is opposite from
protein biosynthesis
in order to accomplish this each amino
acid will go through protection of
reactive groups
this ensures that when new amino acids
are added to the growing chain
they bind in the c to n format rather
than through the side chain
once protected the first amino acid will
be linked to a resin through its c
terminal so that new amino acids can be
coupled to that amino acids and terminal
as shown here in step three once the
growing amino acid chain is finished
all of the protective groups will be
removed in order to have a fully
reactive peptide this peptide will then
be purified from the resin
using high performance liquid
chromatography or hplc
as you can see through this example
chromatogram in step 5.
at denscript we use three different
types of chemical synthesis
liquid phase synthesis is the original
methodology for synthetic peptide
production
and unlike solid-based synthesis does
not require linking of the first amino
acid to a resin
but instead requires an additional
chemical protective group
on the c-terminus of the first amino
acid because of this synthetic
technology
each new peptide must be manually
purified before addition of the next
amino acid
now while this can be timely and costly
it also ensures
extremely high purity of the final
peptide
also because the c-terminus is not
attached to a resin
it is the preferred method for any
peptide requiring c-terminal
modifications
and is great for large yields solid
phase synthesis is similar to liquid
phase synthesis
however instead of a protective group on
the first amino acid
the c-terminal is linked to a resin this
makes addition of new amino acids
easy and smooth and therefore
significantly reduces turnaround time
as purification can wait until the end
because of the technology
solid phase synthesis is preferred for
long and difficult peptides rather than
bulk production
the most recent advancement in peptide
synthesis is through the use of
automated microwave technology rather
than manual synthesis
microwave synthesis is done entirely
through a machine
and therefore it can significantly
reduce the turnaround time and increase
the overall capacity
to make larger numbers of peptides per
day
in fact genscript's microwave technology
actually doubled our capacity
so now we can chemically synthesize 18
000 peptides per month
because this technology uses microwave
energy it is able to increase turnaround
time by reducing the time required for
coupling and resin separation
this also makes it great for fast
synthesis of difficult shorter peptides
rather than longer ones
the reason we utilize three different
types of chemical synthesis
and a combination thereof including
recombinant production
is because each peptide's intrinsic
characteristics will dictate if a
peptide is difficult to synthesize
and why neo-antigen peptides tend to be
highly difficult to produce
and will require all different types of
synthesis in order to produce highly
pure peptides at required yields
specifically neo-antigen peptides can be
difficult to synthesize
because of these five characteristics
listed here
peptide length charge hydrophobicity
yield and purity for length neoantigen
tend to either be 9 to 11 amino acids
representing the
neoantigen epitope or they will be
larger than 25 amino acids in order to
be processed and presented
by apc's on mhc class 1 and class 2.
peptides over 20 amino acids tend to be
difficult to synthesize and will usually
require a combination of microwave and
solid-based synthesis
for peptide charge because neoantogens
are only expressed in cancer
they tend to contain charge-modifying
amino acids which would not be expressed
within natural
tumor-associated antigens many synthetic
steps
only work with specific isoelectric
points and therefore the further from
neutral a peptide is
the synthesis will be more difficult
third
because neo antigens are produced from
random amino acid indels throughout the
peptide
hydrophobic side chains are bound to be
introduced within the sequence
these hydrophobic side chains will lead
to a stronger chance of aggregation
and therefore limited solubility in
water which in turn makes purification
very difficult neoantogen peptide
synthesis can also be very difficult
because each application within the
various stages of therapeutic
development
will require completely different yields
or peptide mass
as well as purity or percentage of
target peptide within a sample
because of the flexibility required it
can be cumbersome to find a reliable
provider
which is able to accommodate yields
ranging from large-scale micro libraries
of
half a milligram to synthesis of gram
level of one individual peptide
because of this genscript has tailored
its neoantigen peptide synthesis service
to be fully customizable in order to
achieve yields for any application
in terms of purity other than
flexibility required for various
applications
because neolinogen peptides tend to be
hydrophobic and have a tendency to
aggregate
their solubility makes them difficult to
purify using standard techniques
because of this they must be treated
with extra care and go through
additional processes of purification
in order to reach the 98 purity required
for applications like personalized
cancer vaccine generation
and analysis in patient-derived cell
lines
as these are precious samples
in order to accomplish difficult
neo-antigen peptide synthesis
we here at genscript have developed our
own neoantigen peptide synthesis
platform
which utilizes reliable technologies and
tools to achieve a 95
success rate for difficult peptide
synthesis this platform can be divided
into four main stages
in the first stage every neoantigen
peptide sequence which comes through our
order system
is analyzed by our proprietary natal
pre-bioinformatics algorithm
in order to determine synthetic
difficulty and the best method to
synthesize
each peptide based on its predicted
difficulty
in the second stage of genscript's
platform those neoantogen peptides will
be synthesized according to the
recommendation of our neopre algorithm
and our peptide experts using one or a
combination of our synthetic
technologies
ranging from manual liquid and or solid
phase automated microwave technology
recombinant expression or chemical
ligation
in order to understand how we achieve
this 95
success rate for highly difficult
peptides let's dive a little deeper into
gemscript's neopre
analytics tool
genscript's long-standing experience in
peptide synthesis has given us an
opportunity to develop a tool for
estimating ease of peptide synthesis
process
it is necessary to evaluate the
feasibility of all peptide sequences
prior to synthesis
therefore every one of our customers
peptides go through our proprietary
neopre bioinformatics algorithm
to determine synthesis difficulty the
first step in using this tool
is to copy the neoantogen peptide
sequence into the algorithm shown here
if this is the customer facing tool then
once you hit submit you will see a
response indicating how difficult the
synthesis of the peptide will be
if this tool is being used internally
the readout will be much more involved
and highlight the individual
characteristics
that are causing difficult synthesis as
well as the recombinant
or sorry recommended synthetic synthetic
technology
this slide shows an example of what the
readout of the internal algorithm would
look like
the algorithm would analyze the
individual peptide sequences and convert
its intrinsic characteristics to numbers
which correspond to how difficult the
peptide synthesis will be
due to that specific characteristics the
six characteristics that neoprene
analyzes
our tendency for the peptide to
aggregate represented by na4vss
isoelectric point shown as pi
hydrophobicity
sequence length yield and purity
amino acids are shown in red during the
system review
to indicate which ones have strong
tendency to aggregate
for aggregation less than 0 is
considered simple
0 to 20 is considered middle and over 20
is considered hard
while larger hydrophobicity numbers
indicate more difficult sequences
once the algorithm has assessed each
peptide's difficulty
it will determine the predicted
difficulty of synthesizing each peptide
as well as recommend the best means of
successfully synthesizing each
individual peptide
once the just peptide expert reviews the
results they will then adjust the
synthetic methodology as needed based
off javascript 15 years of peptide
synthesis
neopre is able to analyze the numerical
values assigned to individual
characteristics of each peptide in order
to predict the synthetic difficulty
overall genscript has used neopre for
171 peptides for this specific case
study
of those 71 were shown to be difficult
to synthesize
of the 71 difficult peptides 61 were
actually difficult to synthesize
while 10 were actually easier to
synthesize than originally predicted
digging deeper a hundred peptides were
shown to be easy to synthesize
with 78 of them accurately predicted and
22 of them
actually difficult to synthesize with
this tool what's important to understand
is that those 83 total difficult
peptides
were able to be synthesized despite
their high hydrophobicity
long length and tendency to aggregate
since using neopre genscript has
actually been able to synthesize
2158 out of 2267 peptides ordered
giving us an overall success rate of
95.15 percent
37.5 percent of which were delivered
using genscript's rush peptide service
within
five to six days neoantogen peptides
tend to either be focused on epitopes
presented on mhc1 and mhc2 which range
from 9 to 15 amino acids
or they tend to be larger over 20 amino
acids
for 9 to 15 amino acids genscript
synthesized 1835
out of 1806 peptides ordered
giving an overall success rate of 98.18
percent
with the majority of these peptides
being deemed as difficult
synthesizing the larger peptides over 20
amino acids
always tend to be more difficult and
require more attention in synthetic
methodology
and take slightly longer because of this
genscript has synthesized 85.31
of ordered larger peptides
after each neoantogen peptide has been
synthesized
using our neopre and synthetic
technologies they will go through
stringent quality control based
on individual customer and application
needs
all genscript peptides undergo total
quality management testing
including mass spectrometry and
analytical hplc
high performance liquid chromatography
analysis throughout the peptide
synthesis and purification process
through our trademarked acupep quality
control service in addition to the
standard coa document you would receive
genscript offers an additional 12
quality control services
including our endotoxin analysis and
removal service
endotoxins are lipopolysaccharides which
are major components of the cell walls
of gram-negative bacteria
which can be introduced into custom
peptide preparations during synthesis
more importantly they can stimulate a
plethora of unwanted immune reactions in
b cells
macrophages as well as stimulate t cell
expansion even at the lowest
concentration
to enhance your experimental results
genscript offers custom peptides with
guaranteed endotoxin control service
to reduce endotoxin levels at less than
0.01 eu per microgram
which is ideal for most cellular assays
especially on primary cell lines
we also offer guaranteed tfa
measurements and removal
tfa or trifluoroacetic acid is a strong
acid which is commonly used to cleave
synthesized peptides from solid-based
resins
and is also used to improve hplc
performance in the peptide purification
step
although tfa is quite important residual
tfa and custom peptides can cause
inexplicable discrepancies
in subsequent assay data which is why at
gen script we can guarantee tfa values
of less than one percent
in exchange for either acetate or
formate
the last step of junscript's neoantigen
peptide synthesis platform
is peptide optimization in which we can
design seven different types of peptide
libraries in order to narrow down your
perfect neoantigen sequence
the most popular peptide library design
services for neoantogen peptides
are genscript's alanine scanning
overlapping and t cell truncation
libraries
in an alanine scanning library each
amino acid will
sequentially be replaced with an alanine
in turn
this will allow the end user to
determine the most important individual
amino acids to peptide function
as opposed to an alanine scanning
library which replaces individual amino
acids
an overlapping library simply deletes
amino acids over a certain threshold
because of this it is great for
identifying where a neoantogen epitope
is within an
entire neoantigen peptide sequence t
cell truncation libraries are similar to
overlapping libraries
except you can decide on multiple
epitope lengths to put into one pool
in order to tease out the perfect length
of your neoantigen or tcr
i know i have gone over a lot of
information about neo-antigen peptides
and how they are used in personalized
cancer medicine
so now i would like to summarize the key
takeaways from today's presentation
first neoantogens are new or novel
cancer antigens which are present on
cancerous tissue
but not expressed within wild-type
tissue they are expressed within
individual tumors
or tumor cells of a specific patient
rather than being shared amongst
patients suffering from one type of
cancer
second normally neoantogens are not
expressed at a high enough level to be
tracked by the immune system
but because they are not recognized as
self antigens
like common tumor-associated antigens
they are highly immunogenic
third neo-antigen therapeutics can be
either personalized cancer vaccines or
personalized t-cell therapies
both of these therapeutics require
neo-antigen peptides for various stages
of functionality and efficacy screening
fourth genscript's neopre bioinformatics
algorithm
allows javascript to synthesize highly
hydrophobic difficult peptides
by analyzing the individual amino acid
sequence
for hydrophobicity length aggregation
charge yield and purity to identify
synthetic difficulty
and the technology to synthesize each
peptide
and lastly genscript's neoantigen
peptide services
offer a reliable synthesis by being a
trustworthy partner
having a high success rate for difficult
peptide synthesis
and flexible services for all precision
therapeutic applications
i want to thank you for attending my
presentation today and i am happy to
answer any questions you may have
but while you are typing your questions
into the chat box i would quickly like
to mention
that genscript's neoantigen peptide
synthesis service produces reliable
neoantigen peptides for precision
therapeutic discovery
this is because at gen script we have
the technical means and experience to
synthesize large numbers of challenging
neoantogen peptides
and provide tailored optimization tools
for your downstream applications
we are able to accomplish this by
providing a trustworthy user experience
demonstrated through our work with over
50 of the world's leading immuno
oncology organizations
at 95 success rate for difficult
neoantogen peptide synthesis
and our extreme service flexibility
putting our customers in the driver's
seat of their entire project
no matter what the application again
thank you for your attention and i am
looking forward to answering your
questions
thank you